[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
el espacio el cosmos el universo es una
idea un lugar un concepto que lleva
acechando la mente del ser humano desde
hace literalmente miles y miles de años
desde tiempos inmemorables nuestra
especie se ha visto fuertemente
interesada e influenciada por los astros
pensar un momento se podría entender la
historia del comercio marítimo sin el
astrolabio había sido acaso posible el
desarrollo de la agricultura en europa
de la edad media si no se hubiera
prestado atención al cosmos algo que por
ejemplo ayudaba a nuestros antepasados a
saber cuándo era el momento óptimo para
cada etapa de los cultivos y por
supuesto más allá de estudiar el
universo por necesidad no podemos
olvidar ni tampoco negar que los astros
han tenido también un fuerte influjo una
enorme atracción un asombroso poder para
hacer volar nuestra fantasía imaginación
amigos ya en el siglo dos escritores
como luciano de samósata fantaseaban en
sus relatos verídicos con la idea de
alcanzar las estrellas de ver mundos
extraterrestres y éste imaginaba guerras
entre los monarcas de otros planetas y
no fue un caso aislado desde entonces
muchos otros como cyrano de bergerac
daniel defoe y como no julio verne
siguieron fantaseando con volar a los
lejanos mundos extraterrestres pero
amigos tranquilos que este vídeo no va
sobre la historia de la astronomía
ah
el 20 de diciembre de 2019 el presidente
de los eeuu donald trump firmó como
suele ser habitual por estas fechas el
presupuesto de defensa para el año
siguiente sin embargo en ese acta la s
1790 hubo algo que no fue nada rutinario
amigos ese día con su firma la base
militar de andrews el presidente donald
trump creó la iese de la fuerza espacial
de los eeuu y la pregunta es puesto algo
más que un mero titular ha existido
antes algo parecido en los eeuu es que
acaso existen planes para militarizar el
espacio con armas orbitando alrededor de
la tierra pues bien hoy responderemos a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
toca ver algo de historia
[Música]
la carrera por el dominio del espacio
años 50 guerra fría dos gigantes
enfrentados un pulso entre el comunismo
y el capitalismo unión soviética versus
eeuu amigos podemos decir que el
pistoletazo de salida que marcó el
comienzo de la carrera espacial lo dio
la unión soviética el 4 de octubre de
1957 ese día el satélite sputnik 1 fue
puesto en órbita y como os podéis
imaginar en el país del rock and roll
el lanzamiento del sputnik sentó peor
que mal fue algo totalmente inesperado y
para colmo ahí no quedó todo menos de un
mes más tarde la urss se lanzaba al
espacio su es público 2 tristemente
famoso por llevar como tripulante a la
pobrecilla perrita laika el caso es que
no fue hasta el año siguiente hasta 1958
cuando los estadounidenses pudieron
finalmente mover su ficha desde la
casilla de salida de esta particular
carrera lo hicieron con el lanzamiento
de su primer satélite el explorer one
bueno
pero amigos aunque los estadounidenses
se pusieron las pilas con su primer
satélite y con la creación de la nasa en
el 59 en 1961 los soviéticos volvieron a
dejar al mundo sin palabras el 12 de
abril de ese año un joven yuri gagarín
se convirtió en la primera persona en
navegar por el espacio a su regreso fue
recibido como todo un superhéroe
internacional y ojo un apunte tan solo
una semana después le siguió el
estadounidense alan shepard pero claro
este partido ya lo habían ganado en
moscú y es que podemos decir que 'no un
soviética durante esta primera parte de
la carrera espacial y estuvo claramente
por delante la urss consiguió concluir
exitosamente misión trasmisión abandonar
la órbita terrestre aterrizar en la luna
si en la luna e incluso emprender la
primera misión a venus parecían
imparables luna 9 fue la primera misión
de aterrizaje suave en la luna la nave
espacial soviética llegó tres años antes
de que los primeros humanos salieran a
la superficie era parte de un programa
de largo alcance de la unión soviética
para fotografiar y aprender más sobre la
luna sin embargo un momento porque el
día 25 de mayo de 1961 pasó algo que
cambiaría para siempre la posición de
las fichas en este particular tablero
[Música]
ese día ya un pitcher al que me vi
pronunció un discurso ante el congreso
de los eeuu en el que fijó una nueva
prioridad nacional hacer que el hombre
el hombre estadounidense claro pisara la
luna y volviera sano y salvo a casa y
además tenían que lograrlo antes de que
llegara su fin esa misma década de los
60 y como sabemos decir por aquí dicho y
hecho el 20 de julio de 1969 los
estadounidenses apuntaron tanta
inigualable en la historia ese diana y
la nuestro pisó la luna marcando un gran
salto para la humanidad
o sea
o
pero vale está todo esto hasta aquí es
algo que de una forma u otra todos
sabremos sin embargo estamos en visual
político nuestro papel aquí es intentar
mirar más allá y ver qué peso qué papel
y qué influencia política tuvo esta
especie de competición por las estrellas
y eso eso es exactamente lo que vamos a
hacer y lo primero lo primero para
entender toda esta historia es echar un
vistazo a la principal diferencia que
durante décadas existió entre el
programa espacial soviético y el
norteamericano
[Música]
y es que veréis aunque la unión
soviética militar hizo su carrera
espacial desde muy pronto digamos que
esto fue algo que los yankees no se
plantearon en un principio no al menos
en los mismos términos veréis me explicó
el mismísimo presidente y san javier el
general dwight de witiza hauer ayc para
los amigos escribió de hecho a burga
ning presidente entonces del consejo de
ministros de la urss y el crochet su
homólogo soviético una serie de cartas
en el 57 y en el 58 para convencerles de
que hicieran de la misión espacial un
proyecto digamos de cooperación
científica entre ambos países en lugar
de una carrera de competición por
supuesto fracaso aunque los yankees no
tiraron la toalla poco después crearon
la nasa siguiendo exactamente ese mismo
espíritu como una agencia completamente
civil e independiente y no sólo eso
gracias además a la space acn de 1958
los científicos norteamericanos tuvieron
mucha libertad para llevar a cabo sus
investigaciones sobre el espacio algo
muy pero que muy distinto a lo que
ocurrió en la urss cuya misión espacial
estaba hace realmente controlada por el
ministerio de maquinaria general un
ministerio subordinado a la comisión de
industria militar de la unión soviética
[Música]
pese a todo ya office era el que me lo
volvió a intentar siguiendo la estela de
eisenhower jfk trato de conseguir que la
carrera espacial se convirtiera en un
espacio de distensión y cooperación con
su entonces archienemigo de la hoz y el
martillo y de hecho en su primer
discurso como presidente pronunció estas
palabras
en el texto pero amigos cruces volvió a
hacer oídos sordos oídos sordos hasta
que en 1962 los eeuu consiguieron poner
a john glenn en órbita ahí a ella por
fin los soviéticos empezaron a tantear
el terreno de una posible cooperación
espacial con los yankees y por supuesto
la masa cogió el guante al instante los
entonces dos grandes archienemigos
llegaron a un acuerdo sin precedentes un
acuerdo por el que se comprometían a
compartir entre otras cosas pronósticos
meteorológicos y si vale vale no se
seque esto puede parecer poca cosa pero
pensad lo que supuso como símbolo y todo
ello por no hablar del ambiente casi
paranoico por el secretismo que se vivía
en la unión soviética de hecho no
penséis que fue coser y cantar para nada
los propios científicos jefes de la
unión soviética como por ejemplo fue el
caso de sis la piel del presidente de la
academia de las ciencias no acaban de
ver por qué demonios compartir sus
hallazgos con el enemigo aunque se
tratara de menos datos meteorológicos y
es que claro el contexto de la terrible
fijaos si no en el caso del propio
kelvis el presidente de la academia de
las ciencias mirad mirad que el 10 fue
parte del secretismo paranoide durante
muchos años el nombre de que el dis fue
secreto de estado sólo se le conocía
como el anónimo jefe teórico de la
cosmonáutica ronald zak de jeff físico
ruso y antiguo director del instituto de
investigación espacial ruso vamos que
quien dice algo así como el voldemort de
la opción martillo y por si tanta
desconfianza no era suficiente entonces
brees nc llegó al kremlin y volvió a
tirar del freno de mano a todo eso de
hablar con los americanos
leonid bréznev había sido anteriormente
el comisario de todos los temas
relacionados con la industria militares
del politburó y amigos león y león y
tenía claro que la urss estaba en clara
ventaja y que no tenía ningún sentido
colaborar con los yankees para que
ayudarles y podían vencerle pero se
equivocó bréznev cometió un grave error
porque pues porque pocos años más tarde
la administración nixon es adelantaría
por la derecha con un neil amstrong
caminando por la luna y poniendo la
banderita de los eeuu en la superficie
de nuestro astro vecino amigos con el
pasito lunar de armstrong el ánimo en el
kremlin dejó de ser el mismo y entonces
de repente plot twist por quienes
aparecieron gregory peck y gene hackman
en escena sí sí
peck y jactan los actores breaks no me
ha vuelto loco resulta que en 1970 en
una reunión del más alto nivel entre
científicos soviéticos y estadounidenses
los yanquis salieron con algo que
dejarían los de la hoz y el martillo muy
pero que muy perdidos
[Música]
reed helder entonces presidente de la
academia de las ciencias de los estados
unidos le empezó a hablar aquel dis el
jefe científico de la unión soviética de
una película que se había estrenado en
hollywood la película maroon o
abandonados en el espacio como se
conocía en españa' relataba la historia
de tres astronautas estadounidenses que
se quedaban perdidos en el espacio y
eran rescatados por cosmonautas
soviéticos
y nos digamos que los de la hoz y el
martillo pues no acaban de entender todo
esto muy bien como en hollywood estaban
haciendo propaganda soviética pero
aunque narices pues ojo porque hard leer
les consiguió convencer de que ante una
situación catastrófica como la que se
graba en la película era necesario tener
sistemas compatibles para poder actuar
conjuntamente y atentos porque llegaron
a un acuerdo y no precisamente a uno
simbólico sino un acuerdo histórico en
plena guerra fría con prácticamente
ambos países manteniendo sus respectivos
dedos encima del botón nuclear estos dos
grandes enemigos firmaron la pipa de la
paz para desarrollar el proyecto de
colaboración apolo soyuz impresionante
me pasó pero decidí aprender por
[Aplausos]
en progress software y leonid press
sin embargo amigos el día 20 de enero de
1981 la estrategia espacial de los eeuu
daría un giro de 180 grados amigos ese
día un nuevo hombre llegó a la casa
blanca atento
[Música]
la guerra de las galaxias'
el día 20 de enero de 1981 ronald wilson
reagan entró en la casa blanca con una
idea aparentemente algo loca en utilizar
el arsenal nuclear de la archienemiga
unión soviética su objetivo logra así
que ese concepto esa idea de la
destrucción mucho aseguraba quedará
totalmente obsoleta si quería simple y
llanamente cargarse dedicadas estrategia
militar
la gente de community en el alcance
todos los núcleos de tener greater nauta
decorosamente en europa te llevas
también es hablando índices núcleo web
nos importa en absoluto
y la pregunta la gran pregunta es como
demonios pensaba el entonces presidente
de los eeuu convertir todo el poderío
nuclear soviético en apenas un montón de
viejos ladrillos obsoletos pues amigos
para responder esta cuestión os hago
otra pregunta os suena de algo la guerra
de las galaxias' pues tal cual
[Música]
pero no agregaban presentó el 23 de
marzo de 1983 la s de la strategic
defense initiative más conocida como la
iniciativa de las star wars su objetivo
era construir un sistema tanto terrestre
como espacial capaz de desmantelar y
aniquilar cualquier intento de ataque
nuclear soviético pero un momento esto
es algo muy fácil de decir pero la
pregunta es cómo diantres hacerlo
pues lo cierto es que a pesar de todo al
principio no había una idea clara al
respecto los científicos y expertos
plantearon muchas posibilidades desde
armas láser instaladas en la tierra y en
el espacio hasta diferentes tipos de
misiles y sistemas de localización sin
embargo más tarde la apuesta que parece
que se llevó el gato al agua porque todo
esto es un asunto de 'top secret' de
máxima confidencialidad fue la de
desarrollar pequeños misiles lanzados
desde el propio espacio conocidos como
brilliant pebbles que en castellano
sería algo así como piedrecitas
brillantes
sí sí ya sabéis que todo siempre suena
mejor mi ex y de esta forma la idea de
reagan era conseguir la obsolescencia
del sistema militar nuclear soviético
dejando a las totalmente desnuda en
materia ofensiva y defensiva pero a ver
era un farol o acaso reagan lo creía
posible pues la verdad es que poco
importaba la cuestión era que creía
exactamente la unión soviética y amigos
parece que todo esto de la st y de las
star wars sí que les preocupaba mucho la
unión soviética creyó que el gran
potencial tecnológico de los eeuu había
marcado un gol y trató las palabras de
reagan como una amenaza real
anatoly dobrynin embajador de la unión
soviética en los eeuu de 1962 a 1986
quizás deberíamos dejar de temer a la
sda y por supuesto que no podemos
simplemente ignorar este peligroso
programa pero deberíamos superar nuestra
obsesión con el están apostando todo a
nuestro miedo en la sdi en términos
morales políticos y militares están
persiguiendo que este programa no se
agote
gorbachov en un discurso al politburó en
marzo de 1986
y si lo cierto es que en el kremlin
estaban empezando a obsesionarse con
todo esto de las star wars porque claro
pensando los momentos y reagan realmente
se estaba echando un farol y no tenían
la tecnología ya pero si si sería el fin
pues bien el caso es que los soviéticos
que empezaban a sentirse acorralados no
se quedaron de brazos cruzados y
subieron la apuesta en 1987 desde el
cosmódromo de baikonur los soviéticos
lanzaron la nave espacial militar polyus
una nave que estaba equipada con un
sistema de láseres que un sistema de
misiles cáscara su objetivo echar abajo
la sdi espacial de reagan poniendo en
órbita su propia mega arma
el resultado la verdad es que no
lograron ponerla en órbita y la nave
éxito pedazos en un abrir y cerrar de
ojos y de esta forma es como la
estrategia de las star wars se convirtió
en un arma de negociación sin
precedentes para la administración
reagan
[Música]
no lo dudéis cada vez que de reagan y
gorbachov se sentaban las star wars
alien siempre siempre en la cumbre
bilateral de género del 85 de la de
rayados del 86 el amigo 137
moscú del 88 etcétera etcétera hdi
demostró ser la pieza negociadora
definitiva y la jugábamos para todo lo
que importaba george shultz secretario
de estado bajo la administración reagan
el caso es que llegados a los 90 con la
unión soviética ya colapsada pues las
starwars parecieron carecer de sentido y
amigos aunque formalmente nunca se
llegara a cancelar el programa su
presupuesto fue drásticamente recortados
de la caída de la unión soviética pero
entonces ya está terminó la guerra fría
y con ello el concepto del espacio como
campo de batalla pues no para nada aún
hay más muchísimo más en enero del 2001
llega de un nuevo punto de inflexión en
términos de política espacial ese mes
donald rafael futuro secretario de
defensa de la nueva administración de
george walker bush alertó al congreso
desde una comisión independiente que él
mismo presidía de un nuevo peligro
inminente eeuu estaba al borde de sufrir
un nuevo pearl harbor y en esta ocasión
un pearl harbor espacial atentos
[Música]
las fuerzas espaciales
amigos según los últimos datos
disponibles los eeuu tienen el momento
de preparar este vídeo 1.327 satélites
operativos en órbita de los cuales
aproximadamente un 30 por ciento
pertenecen al gobierno o al ejército
ningún otro país tiene tantos satélites
de hecho para que os hagáis una idea
según las estimaciones existentes rusia
tendría unos 169 y china- 363 es decir
juntos apenas sumarían un 40 por ciento
de los de la potencia yanqui y amigos no
lo dudéis ni un instante la influencia
de estos satélites estadounidenses en
nuestro día a día es inmensa no hay una
sola jornada que no uséis uno cuando
pedí su nube y os avisa de cuándo ha
llegado cuando viajes en avión cuando
hacéis una transferencia a través de la
web de vuestro banco etcétera etcétera y
por supuesto como os podéis imaginar la
cosa no se queda solo en el campo civil
en el mundo militar los satélites se han
vuelto una herramienta clave
comunicaciones navegación reconocimiento
detección de misiles fijación de
objetivos tenerlo claro la guerra del
presente y del futuro se libra desde el
espacio
[Música]
de esta forma tal y como apuntaba la
comisión ranz velen en 2001 cuando
alertó sobre un potencial per harbor
espacial un ataque coordinado contra
satélites militares estadounidenses si
que podría dejar ciego inoperativo al
ejército más poderoso de la tierra cómo
iban a controlar sus drones cómo iban a
poder saber lo que está pasando en una
ubicación antes de poner un pie en el
terreno cómo comunicarse con las tropas
[Música]
paradójicamente el mismo espacio que les
permitió inocular el miedo al enemigo en
tiempos pasados está hoy preocupando y
mucho muchísimo al gigante
norteamericano y no es para menos en los
últimos años países no precisamente
aliados como por ejemplo china han
demostrado ser capaces de destruir
satélites con misiles sin despeinarse
[Música]
el derecho ya en 2007 en una
demostración de fuerza por parte de
pekín el gigante chino destruye uno de
sus satélites meteorológicos el frame 11
con un misil de medio alcance sc 19 un
misil que aunque se lanzó sin carga
explosiva logró la destrucción del
satélite por la mera colisión con este y
por cierto un dato dicha colisión
controlada generó más de 3.000
fragmentos que orbitan alrededor de la
tierra en forma de residuos espaciales
no hay registro de ningún evento
espacial que haya generado tantos
residuos como esta operación y ojo
porque debido a la velocidad con la que
circulan en el espacio incluso las
partículas más pequeñas pueden ser muy
peligrosas para satélites en
funcionamiento estaciones espaciales o
cohetes
[Música]
pero la cosa no quedó ahí en 2013 china
lanzó al espacio una nueva arma anti
satélites pero esta vez muchísimo más
lejos llegó a alcanzar unos 18 mil 600
millas de distancia llegando a rozar en
términos espaciales claro satélites
estadounidenses que se encontraban a 22
mil millas de distancia con la tierra en
esta ocasión sin alegó que se trataba
tan sólo de un experimento científico
nada de lo que preocuparse pero hoy hoy
sabemos que sería lo que hizo china no
otra cosa que probará el desempeño de su
nueva arma el dongting 2 un misil tierra
espacio con capacidad de alcanzar la
órbita terrestre alta es decir hablamos
de más de 20 mil millas de distancia
todos estos eventos hicieron que en la
casa blanca resonaron las palabras de
rangel con sup el hardware espacial que
precisamente por eso a finales de 2014
tal y como cuenta daghlas loberro
subsecretario de defensa para política
espacial barack obama dio la orden de
incorporar en los presupuestos una
partida para retomar las investigaciones
en este campo de la defensa espacial
pero queridos amigos de visual político
llegados a este punto la pregunta es y
moscú es que acaso vladimir putin se
quedó mirando de brazos cruzados
mientras la china de hu jintao inés y
limpie y se preparaba para una posible
contienda espacial pues no para nada
[Aplausos]
en el 2017 contraria en la casa blanca
la federación rusa lanzó un cohete
atentos del que salió un satélite del
que luego a su vez salieron otros dos
satélites más la comunidad militar si le
llegó a poder como los razzie danés team
sad a lights algo así como los satélites
matrioska en castellano pues bien estos
satélites empezaron a hacer maniobras
llegando a poder cambiar de órbita con
la impredecibilidad que yo conlleva y
aquí no queda todo en otra ocasión otros
satélites rusos siguió a varios
satélites de eeuu y de aliados por
supuesto hay que ser einstein para
imaginar que si tu objetivo es poder
destruir satélites tener la tecnología
para ponerte a su lado es un paso muy
importante
[Música]
pero en el país del rock and roll cómo
se gestionó todo este asunto pues veréis
aunque en eeuu históricamente todo lo
relacionado con el espacio se había
canalizado a través de las fuerzas
aéreas y en agosto de 2019 tran reactivó
el comando espacial de regla y ojo
porque la reactivación de esta división
fue tan sólo el primer paso hasta que a
finales de ese mismo año tran decretó la
creación de la fuerza espacial de los
eeuu con algo menos de 20 mil hombres
esta nueva rama del ejército vestida por
cierto con uniforme de camuflaje porque
según se alega el personal de las frases
espaciales piensa su nombre está
desplegado en tierra se encarga de
entrenarse ante posibles escenarios
adversos relacionados con los satélites
[Música]
imaginaos por ejemplo que un comando
está a punto de desplegarse para llevar
a cabo una misión especial y que en ese
momento el satélite con el que se
comunican con su mando falla en ese
momento entra en acción una división de
la ss efe que se encargaría de reasignar
un satélite nuevo al comando además y el
fallo del satélite fuera fruto de un
ataque se encargarían de estudiar como
inutilizar ha llegado el caso de
destruir a ese agente externo y con lo
cual hay que decir que no existe la
actualidad una visión clara y
consensuada sobre que deberían de ser
estas fuerzas espaciales parece que la
más aceptada sería la de una especie de
fuerza light al estilo de la guardia
costera es decir que tendría la misión
de garantizar en la medida de lo posible
un entorno espacial seguro para los
satélites comerciales tanto
estadounidenses como de sus aliados
luego por su parte en toda esta historia
china y rusia han jugado una baza
negociadora fuerte si no queréis que
instalemos armas en el espacio hagamos
un acuerdo donde firmemos y nos
comprometamos todos a ello pero en esta
ocasión la respuesta de eeuu ha sido
tajante no ni de broma
los norteamericanos dicen que no tienen
la seguridad de poder verificar que el
acuerdo se cumpla y que además eso no
impediría la acumulación de dispositivos
anti satélites en tierra listos para
lanzarse al espacio así que y vosotros
qué pensáis si estuviera en vuestra mano
firmaría un acuerdo de este tipo
confiando en la contraparte o pondré
todos los recursos posibles para ser los
primeros en alcanzar la superioridad
tecnológica dejamos tu respuesta aquí
abajo en los comentarios y ya sabes si
esta ayuda resulta interesante no
olvides darle al botón de like y por
cierto si te gusta todo lo relacionado
con el espacio no te pierdas este vídeo
que hemos hecho megaproyecto sobre la
estación espacial internacional en fin
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]